good morning John this video I kind of
want to give you half a semester of
college level chemistry and I only have
four minutes to do it so I'm gonna get
started everything in the world is made
up of atoms atoms are very small atoms
have protons and neutrons in their
nucleus and electrons orbiting those
protons and neutrons a number of protons
in an atom tells you what kind of atom
it is by which I mean what element that
atom is
protons are positively charged and
electrons are negatively charged by
definition atoms have no charge so if
they have 14 protons they have 14
electrons if they have a different
number of protons and electrons then
they're an ion not an atom the number of
neutrons in an atom can vary not just
element by element but individual atom
by atom of the same element that's
enough about protons and neutrons let's
talk about electrons electrons orbit the
nucleus of an atom in specific orbitals
and electron orbitals really like to be
full orbitals come in four basic flavors
s P D and F s orbitals contain two
electrons P orbitals can contain up to
six DS 10 and F 14 orbitals fill in the
following order s and then S than P then
S then P indeed then s been peed and D
and then F so if you have one electron
in your atom if you are hydrogen for
example then you have one electron and
your first S orbital if you are carbon
then you have six so you have two
electrons in your first S orbital two
electrons in your second S orbital and
then two electrons in your first p
orbital that is denoted as shown below
1s2 2s2 2p2
to p2v2 so basically carbon is four
electrons away from being happy because
those electron orbitals aren't full
they're a little bit like bella without
edward so how can Bella fill her Edward
shaped hole I mean how can carbon get
those extra four electrons carbon does
that pretty much invariably by linking
to other atoms carbon will then
basically share its electrons with other
atoms while those other atoms are
sharing its electrons with carbon and if
it shares with hydrogen you end up with
things like methane or if it shares with
oxygen you wind up things like carbon
dioxide oddly enough those are the two
principal greenhouse gases Bella Swan
why must you fill your orbitals these
kinds of bonds in which atoms overcome
their initial repulsion in order to
share electrons and make their orbitals
happy are called covalent bonds covalent
bonds are not the only type of bond
sodium for example only needs to lose
one electron and order firts
orbitals to be happy chlorine on the
other hand only needs to get one
electron in order for its orbitals to be
happy so what happens when chlorine and
sodium see each other isn't
of sharing an electron sodium actually
gives its electron to chlorine
permanently but then they're so close
together that because this is now
negatively charged and this is
positively charged they stick together
and then exalt when atoms or molecules
make or break new covalent or ionic
bonds their properties drastically
changed sodium on its own for example
explodes when you put it in water and
chlorine obviously chlorine gas is
extremely deadly but then when you bomb
them together ionically they become
delicious on food physical changes like
melting or freezing or breaking or
vaporizing do not change the fundamental
properties of the atom or molecule if
the chemical changes that are really
fascinating and that's what chemistry is
about if we could talk more about
chemistry John we would talk more in
depth about chemical reactions what
kinds of chemical reactions there are
and why atoms and molecules like to
react in different ways unfortunately we
don't have time for that so you're just
going to have to deal with having as
much knowledge as you have about
chemistry now which is infinitely more
than you had four minutes ago John I
will see you on Monday a quick note
there are three messages that I would
like to bring you in this video that do
not have anything to do with chemistry
one Shawn Ahmed who is a kick-ass
nerdfighter who's been doing amazing
work in Bangladesh is one of the five
finalists who was picked to possibly go
to the World Economic Forum in Davos
Sean will be representing the cause of
global poverty the amazing power of
YouTube and of course nerdfighteria it
would be great if everyone would follow
the link in the sidebar and go vote for
him too obviously the situation in Haiti
is dire and we all need to help in
whatever way we can one really easy way
to help us to text Haiti to nine oh nine
nine nine this will charge an extra $10
to your cellphone bill which will be
donated 100% to the Red Cross mission to
help Haiti if you want to give more than
ten dollars which I hope you do there's
a link to the Red Cross in the sidebar 3
if after you're done with those things
you still have some more time
my favorite fictional YouTube show robot
ninja and gay guy has been nominated for
a Streamy award and you can go and vote
for that in the sidebar as well that's
all thank you hope you learned something
bye